em um país com tantas coisas para serem
feitas por que tem tanta gente sem
trabalho
essa pergunta pode parecer boba pra
vocês mas ela me acompanhou por muitos
anos quando era criança assistia o
jornal com meus pais e eles sempre
tentava me explicar o que estava
acontecendo mas para essa pergunta
eles nunca me deram uma resposta que me
convencesse hoje depois de alguns anos
eu consigo entender por que esse cenário
existe mas eu ainda não consigo me
conformar com essa realidade
e essa minha curiosidade aumenta ainda
mais quando eu vivenciei a educação
pública brasileira na universidade
pública mas a escola estadual no
interior de são paulo mesmo quando a
minha família passou por uma dificuldade
financeira
o movimento que eu fiz foi sair da
escola privada média onde eu tinha
professores tinha a lição de casa e
passar por uma escola pública também
média 100 professores seleção de casa
com muita violência e pouquíssimas
perspectivas de futuro e isso foi o que
mais me chamou a atenção
o problema não é que lá as pessoas
tinham menos dinheiro ou menos
capacitação mas elas tinham menos
perspectiva sobre onde nós queriam
chegar quando estava no sexto ano do
fundamental
meu sonho era um dia fazer faculdade
como meus pais tinham feito mas esse não
parecia seu sonho dos meus colegas por
terem repetido de ano ou abandonado a
escola eles já eram bem mais velhos
alguns já tinham sido presos e vários já
tinham filhos
as referências que eles tinham eram
muito diferentes
eu acabei conseguindo sair dali
ganhei uma bolsa para uma ótima escola
na minha cidade
fiz faculdade me formei em engenharia
foi trabalhar numa consultoria
depois de alguns anos na consultoria a
minha empresa começou um projeto com a
secretaria estadual de educação
o amazonas eu fiz de tudo para poder ser
alocada naquele projeto que na verdade
não foi tão difícil assim porque poucos
condutores que iria trocar a vida em são
paulo para morar em manaus
quando cheguei lá eu fiquei maravilhada
por que de repente eu comecei a entender
tudo aquilo que acontecia lá na minha
escola do fundamental
eu consegui entender o que estava por
trás dos problemas
eu entendia por exemplo porque não tinha
professor na sala de aula eu entendi o
desafio de se fazer um concurso treinar
os professores capacitá-los decidir a
remuneração os incentivos corretos e dá
um suporte para essa profissão que é uma
das mais importantes e mais desafiadoras
por trás de toda escola e toda a sala de
aula existe uma estrutura que explica
estes resultados que a gente só vê na
ponta
assim como esses desafios existem no
setor da educação pública eles também
estão em outros setores do governo e
isso se reflete nos serviços públicos
que são oferecidos para a população na
segurança na saúde na mobilidade mas
mais importante do que aprender como
todas essas coisas funcionavam
eu conseguia também entender que eu era
capaz de mudar aquelas coisas com as
quais eu não concordava e por mais que
os processos fossem burocráticos e
lentos como a gente imagina que é no
governo de fato é cada coisa
cada pequena coisa que a gente mudava
tinha um impacto imenso porque isso
mudava a vida de milhares e milhões de
pessoas e isso é o que eu acho que é
mais apaixonante no setor público porque
não existe nenhuma outra organização
maior do que o governo capaz de causar
30 tanto a transformação social no país
mas eu aprendi isso tudo me mostrou que
outras pessoas não tinham essa visão e
não entendiam porque eu era tão
apaixonada por essa por essa esfera e
isso me fez ver que existe um ciclo
vicioso que fazia com
que as porque fazia com que o governo
não tivesse dificuldade de atrair
pessoas para trabalhar em suas equipes
porque o governo é percebido pela
população como um lugar burocrático e
corrupto e isso afasta as pessoas que
querem trabalhar com impacto social em
escala o que por sua vez faz com que o
governo seja um lugar ainda menos
atraente mas eu conhecia a pessoa dentro
do governo que estavam comprometidos em
fazer a mudança que eram sérias eram
altamente capacitadas e ao mesmo tempo
eu conhecia a pessoa fora do governo que
queriam trabalhar com mais propósito
para poder melhorar o país
mas não sabiam por onde começar toda
essa inquietação que era minha mas
também de outros jovens nos motivou a
criar o programa trainee gestão pública
do vetor brasil cujo objetivo é
exatamente esse conectar esses jovens
com os governos o que basicamente a
gente faz é atrair selecionar e
desenvolver talentos para trabalhar com
a equipe sérias e comprometidas dentro
do setor público
o nosso objetivo com isso é combater o
estereótipo que as pessoas têm com o
governo e assim podemos gerar mudanças
estruturantes no país
quando a gente começou a gente recebeu
muitas mensagens de incentivos mas
também muitas ponderações e críticas
na verdade no começo a gente via muitos
rostos assustados
algumas pessoas diziam que ninguém ia
querer denunciar seu trabalho no setor
privado para ir tentar sozinho acabar
com a burocracia brasileira e outras
diziam que nenhum governo ea querer
pessoas ali novas bisbilhotando que eles
estavam fazendo e eu fico muito feliz de
saber que a gente não deu ouvido a essas
colocações porque se a gente tivesse
feito isso hoje a gente não teria
histórias como a do eduardo
ele se formou no interior de minas
gerais foi se tornou um trainee gestão
pública do vetor brasil e foi trabalhar
na secretaria
e de governo de são paulo lá ele
desenvolveu diversos projetos dentre
eles o pit gov que atrai empreendedores
startup para que junto com o governo
desenvolvam os projetos para enfrentar
os maiores desafios do estado
o trabalho de eduardo foi tão importante
que no evento de lançamento o governador
agradeceu nominalmente o que ele tinha
feito ou histórias como d'aline
uma bióloga que tinha acabado de
concluir seu mestrado em
sustentabilidade ambiental na suécia e
foi trabalhar na criação de uma central
de atendimentos na secretaria municipal
de salvador que beneficiou milhares de
pessoas que dependiam daquele
atendimento ou histórias como o
guilherme que saiu de curitiba deixando
para trás seus amigos e seus familiares
e foi morar em belém para trabalhar na
secretaria estadual de educação do pará
em menos de um ano o guilherme retornou
sub coordenador de um projeto de mais de
200 milhões de dólares ou histórias como
alexandre depois de ter sido trainee lá
no governo de goiás e ter percebido que
ele podia fazer a diferença
o alexandre deu um passo além ele se
candidatou à prefeitura da sua cidade no
interior de pernambuco para romper com a
polícia política que é praticada em
tantas cidades brasileiras
quando a gente conversa o alexandre me
conta sobre seus altos e baixos de se
fazer uma campanha limpa com poucos
recursos e ainda assim levar uma
mensagem de otimismo a população já tão
desacreditada política assim como
existem essas histórias
nós temos muitas outras nesses dois anos
iniciais do vetor brasil nós já
colocamos mais de 50 jovens em todas as
regiões do brasil ea busca por talentos
no setor público ela não tem uma
bandeira única
nós trabalhamos com governos dos mais
diferentes partidos
a busca dos jovens é muito grande nesses
dois anos nós já recebemos mais de 15
mil candidaturas para o nosso programa e
essa crescente busca é o que alimenta o
ciclo virtuoso da mudança e melhoria da
gestão
assim como existe o vetor brasil existem
muitas outras iniciativas de indivíduos
e instituições que querem construir
governo os melhores
a gente tem de achar que a política
fazer uma boa política se restringe a
eleger bons candidatos
sim isso é o primeiro passo mas não é o
último porque a política depende do
engajamento de todos e ela vai além das
eleições têm já muita coisa que está
sendo feita mas ainda existe muito mais
para ser criado
é por isso que eu faço o convite seja
você a mudança que quer ver no governo
obrigada